Ever wonder why it’s so hard to kill a cockroach?
Cockroaches’ bodies are built
to compress
Though about 9 mm tall
They can squeeze through a crack of just 3 mm,
barely slowing down their 60 cm per
second speed as they wiggle through
Researchers measured this compressibility
by filming these insects as they
escaped from containers with ever narrower slits.
They also showed that roach
bodies can withstand 900 times their own
weight without sustaining any damage.
Using the practically unstoppable cockroach
as a model, they built a 6-legged robot called
CRAM.
Like the cockroach, it has an outer shell
consisting of movable hard plates, and the
L-shaped
legs have “spines” on them that enable
the legs to get traction even when they are
splayed out from being compressed.
At maximum, the small robot can be compressed
into a space half its 75-mm height
When somewhat compressed, as pictured here,
the robo-roach can travel 14 cm a second
an order of magnitude faster than robotic
worms and other soft robots.
Researchers are already testing larger robots
for disaster search and rescue operations.
But these cockroach bots can crawl through
spaces one-tenth the size that existing bots can.
So at last, this built-in squishability can be used for something other than sneaking
into  kitchens.